[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
virtual edition of our year-round
screening series
film independent presents uh i'm so
happy you joined us here this morning
um to welcome the cast and crew of the
queen's gambit
first off i'd like to thank some of our
supporters our lead sponsor the
hollywood foreign press association the
hfpa has been
an art and supporter of this program and
a film independent for many years
and we are so grateful for their support
especially right now
uh also to our media partner the los
angeles times and to our screening
partner vision media
we have a guest moderator today uh
janelle riley
she is the deputy editor deputy awards
and features editor at variety
and i will let her take it from here
thanks so much
thank you brian i know that title is a
mouthful i appreciate you trying i can't
even say it right
um as he told you my name is janelle
riley thank you for joining us for this
film
independent zoom live with the cast and
creatives behind netflix's
critically acclaimed limited series the
queen's gambit
if you're anything like me you have been
watching the show probably every day the
last week
over and over again uh i want to start
by introducing today's guests uh we'll
start with bill horberg
who is the executive producer of the
series we also have joining us anya
taylor joy who plays the lead elizabeth
harmon
we have actor bill camp who plays mr
scheible
uh actress moses ingram who plays jolene
and also oh we have a special guest we
have actress muriel heller who plays
alma wheatley
and uh a small guest on her lap
that is amazing um thank you all so much
for being here
um whenever i whenever i have people as
accomplished as you all are i i actually
like to go back to the beginning
and ask what was your first job in this
business the first time you felt you
could
call yourself an actor call yourself a
producer
marielle for you i know you're a hugely
successful director
who's now acting as well you're a
complete overachiever
i'm sort of curious what your your first
job in this business was
i originally only thought i was going to
be an actor i started as an actor and
went to theater school and mostly worked
in theater and
only really started directing and
writing
out of frustration and out of feeling
that i wasn't getting to be
creative enough for getting to do enough
cool parts that felt
three-dimensional and like they were
really juicy
so um i hadn't acted in 10 years until
this series so
this is sort of a return to my roots and
it was really
scary for all of those reasons oh wow
and you're amazing i just have to say
you're you're everybody in this cast is
fantastic um
bill camp i'd be curious to hear for you
you have such a
storied career um what was your first
professional job in the business
my first professional job was i i played
the boy
and waiting for godot when i was 10.
um no way way
um the first the first
job i got out of school uh was here in
new york in the park joseph papp
uh gave me a job you know shakespeare in
the in the park in central park and that
was really
i was i was uh i was humbled by
i was extremely excited that i was
getting paid
to actually you know do it and it was uh
it couldn't have you know been more
exciting and
fun and crazy and so i i
felt like you know i i sort of feel this
way every job i get though
it's like every you know it's that old
thing it's like this
could be the last one so i so every job
i'm still
trying to like you know i experienced
that feeling of like
oh i guess i'm pretty good at this i
guess i can get a job
like i can make a living at this i get
to do what i love and so
there's nothing greater but i guess it
was that job
well the good news is your wife is an
incredible actress too so if it stops
for you you're going to
rely on her yeah
exactly anya what about for you
my first ever day on set i was
it was a movie called vampire academy
and i played
feeder girl which means that i got
dragged in
covered in bite marks and basically like
passed around
to the vampires in that room and i just
remember
going back to my trailer that day and
just thinking
this is the most fun i have ever had
like i never want to stop doing this
please let me do this forever
and then they cut me out of the movie
and i was like that's okay
i'm gonna keep going um but my first
like real real job was
the witch and that happened pretty soon
after that and that was
i mean i am currently working with the
same group of people
and it just it feels like home it is
home
and i'm i'm so grateful for that
experience and and to be doing it again
uh looks like we might have lost moses
but i'm sure she'll join in um
soon bill h what about for you
i started in the business in exhibition
i don't know if that makes me an
exhibitionist but uh
i opened a movie theater in chicago
where i grew up
with a high school buddy of mine and it
was uh
it was very funny it had been the
playboy theater in the 70s
so it actually had like bunny logo
carpeting
and a kind of disco brothel
style uh but we were showing old movies
you know hitchcock and
uh werner herzog and um
you know kind of classics and foreign
films
so that was how i kind of got the bug
programming uh films and
making popcorn and chasing rats that was
basically my job
and look where you are now um i actually
want to start at the beginning of the
queen's gambit with you because i know
this series is based on the book of the
same name
by walter tevis um how did you come
across the story can you talk about the
process of adapting it into a limited
series with
the great scott frank and alan scott and
um how did you know you could make chess
so sexy well there's definitely an
origin story and all praise to my
partner alan scott
uh he's a wonderful screenwriter and a
prolific producer
he was the one who optioned the book uh
back in the 80s he actually bought the
rights to the book
outright and almost got it made on
several different occasions with
different actors and directors bernardo
bertolucci at one time
was going to direct a version of the
queen's gambit
young molly ringwald was going to star
in it
so there's a lot of history there and i
met alan
funnily enough on a one of the only
other things i've done
as a television uh series was a show
called fallen angels
that was made for showtime back in the
early 90s
and alan scott wrote one of the episodes
and scott frank
wrote one of the episodes uh and scott
and i
were buddies uh when we first met we
just had a
real instant connection i was a junior
executive at paramount
and he was a young writer in the writers
building there
and we worked on the movie dead again
together you know that kenneth branagh
and emma thompson made so a lot of
history
i got involved probably about 20 years
ago
uh i read the book because michael
anderche
the writer of the english patient told
me this was like one of his favorite
books and he read it every couple years
as
like a touchstone as an author he just
admired the craft of it so much
and i started chasing down the rights
and lo and behold
my friend alan scott turned out to have
the rights and i called them and
you know said would there be any chance
of co-parenting with you
and you know seeing if we could join
forces and
find a way to get this made and he
graciously welcomed me
uh on and scott was one of the people
that i
thought of that i i just had a sense
that he would really dig this material
uh and he read it and loved it and we
spent a little bit
of time trying to get it made as a
feature film um
but it was pretty uphill you know it
wasn't perceived as
commercial enough uh and also
because of the peripatetic nature of the
story and all the disparate
countries and locations it wasn't an
easy film to make
you know cheaply um so we
gave up at a certain point uh and it was
really scott making godless
for netflix that was a total game
changer
um you know the market almost had to
catch up to us
in terms of streaming and the ability to
tell these long-form stories
and in the wake of godless you know they
were looking
to continue the relationship with scott
and he called me and said
you know whatever happened to queen's
gambit is it still around i think the
way to actually do it
now is to expand it and really let it
live and breathe as a character piece
and uh so we took it to netflix
with alan and they said yes
wow and in a way i'm glad it it took
that long because you have the perfect
cast um
i'm guessing anya was like uh you know
probably two years old
when this book first came out um but how
did the script find its way to you
and what attracted you specifically to
the role of beth aside from the amazing
costumes
um there was no script when i signed on
uh i signed on on the book alone the
book and scott that was basically it i
was uh
i was preparing i i already knew that
2019 was going to be a busy year because
i had signed up to two
to do two movies back to back and then i
heard that scott frank wanted to meet me
and he wanted to talk about this
book and i'm not kidding i finished the
book in about an hour and a half
and then i ran to meet scott like
physically ran to that meeting i was so
overwhelmed and excited by the character
and i had all of these ideas and i just
ran into the restaurant and i was like
she has to be a redhead and it's not all
about chess he was like
yes i agree i concur sit down let's eat
something
by the way nice to meet you um
yeah i just i fell in love with her i
really connected with her
feeling of being isolated and being
separate but desperately wanting to find
an
in and then having this magical world
open up that gave her a sense of who she
was um
yeah i just i just fell in love with her
uh marielle you mentioned that uh you
hadn't acted in 10 years
when this found its way to you what was
it specifically about this script that
made you want to return
for me it was also scott you know scott
and i are friends really
were director friends and um on
on a lark i had done a really small part
in his movie a walk among the tombstones
which got
cut out but a day player just for fun
even though i really haven't been
acting in a long time and when i did
that he kind of looked at me and went
oh i didn't i didn't realize you're
actually an actor okay
i'm going to make you act for me one day
it became a threat
um i'm nursing while i talk excuse me
but um
so it became more of a threat from him
and then when this came along
there was another actress who was
supposed to play alma and
uh when she fell out he came to me and
said i want you to play this part and i
was like what are you talking about
netflix will never let you hire me for
this part i haven't acted in 10 years
you have nothing to even look at and he
was like oh they already said yes
and so it was sort of this like
challenge where i had to decide if i was
gonna
say yes to something that sounded kind
of crazy and
fun and out of my comfort zone right now
and um
i don't know how he knew i could do it
but he just had a real sense of it
wow that's fantastic uh bill camp what
about for you
scott he's got the story
the book like anya said um he's uh
he's such a mysterious guy shy ball
that i was attracted you know uh he just
drew me to him
i'm not really sure why uh but sometimes
with there are characters that
that uh present themselves and you sort
of instinctively and
or or eye and kind of instinctively feel
like oh this
this individual could unfold into
something kind of interesting
uh and i didn't know what that would be
but i mean to me he was very
clearly defined in his simplicity and
yet there was a
there was a uh there was some depth i
didn't know what it was or where it came
from or what
but also the act of being of service to
to this young woman uh by
opening a door you know and sort of
responding to her curiosity
really uh i thought was was
was a nice part of the mosaic to be a
part of
you know i'm gonna assume everyone has
seen the show because
everyone has seen the show but also um
you're here so uh if i can get a little
bit spoilery
it's so fascinating to me in in the
final episode when we find that mr
schaible has been
following her career and has all these
clippings and photos and
yeah exactly like you you're just the
hardest cry i've ever had
and i was thinking in some ways you do
your best acting not even on screen
because you built this character so much
that
we our hearts break in that moment
wow one of them janelle what an amazing
compliment
[Laughter]
why on earth did beth not pay mr
scheibel back and a lot of people are
mad at me
and i'm like i didn't write it i'm sorry
i don't know i assume she did until she
said she hadn't i was shocked
no my wife my wife actually pointed that
out
once you open what's what's that check
once marielle's holding that check or
it's like well she's gonna send you
money he's gonna pay you back right
she does right yeah so i think actually
there's a
there's a there's a he's such a he was
such a sort of dark
kind of like uh you know
you don't know a guy that spends all his
time in a basement of an orphanage
you know who knows who that person is or
why they're there or what you know what
is the history there
you know and yet he he's so amazingly
generous
and yet not not in a kind of like i'm
being generous with some sort of string
attached
yeah there's nothing attached it's
unconditional what he gives her
and so i i think that was something
that i don't know and scott it's kind of
amazing too that
anya and bill you guys didn't really
have any scenes together yet i
feel like you're because we're so
attached to young beth
as you it feels like you guys had this
huge history but you probably did you
even
have any scenes together not really yeah
yeah i i got you looked at me out the
window of the car
yeah we met that we met that day we met
we met i got to come into the orphanage
and see a couple of my memories which
was nice
right the same day i did yeah you said
that you were there yeah
and moses welcome back um
uh i am so in love with jolene i mean
she really gets to speak her mind she's
such a fun character
um how did this part find its way to you
and what was the process of sort of
landing that role
my audition just
came in my email just like everything
else um
and i didn't have i just had my sides
but it was just easy language just sort
of just fit in your mouth without doing
much um and i went in the room
and a couple weeks
later skype it's not skype scott wanted
to skype
and we chatted and um he was really
passionate about it and he was like
wow you look really young you could you
could do
young jolene too and i was like really
he was like i think so
he was like let me talk to some people
and then uh not long after that
i found out i booked it and was on my
way
to berlin and you're fairly
fresh out of school is what i understand
is this is your
first tv job is it this is my first
tv job yes so it's amazing to be a part
of this one that is like so
i mean amazing it's great yeah
that's i mean that's incredible uh
you know and especially to be surrounded
by so much talent um was it ever
intimidating
um no i felt very welcomed everyone was
super
patient and generous and kind um
a great place to learn off the back
it was really great
uh i want to talk about the amazing look
of the show especially the costumes
which i
um anya i want your whole wardrobe and i
just saw netflix actually launched a
virtual costume design exhibit today
with the brooklyn museum
it's the queen's gambit and the crown um
i don't want to get on a plane but i
really want to go to new york and see
that
um bill h can you sort of talk about
creating the look of the show and and
for the actors how do these costumes and
these settings inform your characters
well it's a bit improbable uh and
about 90 of this show was made in berlin
so we shot berlin for las vegas berlin
for mexico city
berlin for kentucky berlin for new york
in fact there's not a single moment of
the show as you know that takes place in
berlin
um but it was really uh driven
by this genius production designer
uh julie hanish who's really one of the
top
uh you know people in film in europe i'd
had the pleasure of working with him
maybe 20 years ago with the german
director tom tickfer on a film
uh and scott was looking for somebody to
design the show and we both kind of
immediately said oh babylon berlin that
was just such an incredible
period look where it really looked lived
in and not
you know sometimes period things look
like they're in a glass bubble you know
and preserved in amber um so
he said who designed that and i said
well i know the guy who
he's an old friend let me send him the
book and they skyped and
you know scott immediately fell in love
with them and
so originally we were just going over to
berlin to meet uli
and i thought well we could probably do
paris and moscow
there we've got to go somewhere in
europe and then we got over there
and you know oohy started taking us
around and because the whole city was
built
you know after the war it just had an
incredible variety of
uh uh period appropriate architecture
and then we literally like walked into a
building like you know this could be a
vegas casino it's kind of amazing it
looks
like bobby daron should be singing here
or something
uh and it just kept going like that i
thought well maybe we'll do half the
show here
and it was like a pool table you know
the balls just all
slid down to the other side and you know
we found the high school there
uh so the look you know his whole team
it was his art director his
uh prop team his set decorators
uh you know we just inherited a family
really which was beautiful because they
all had
worked together and had a lot of history
together and then gabrielle
binder who was the costume designer uh
also brilliant woman she had done the
lives of others
you know that oscar-winning uh german
film that
florian uh donna's
von henkel yeah it's a long last name
yeah um so we met her
over there and just loved her and
she'd done a lot of german work but
hadn't really worked on a kind of
international project of scale um
and man she just knocked it out of the
park i mean
uh i i i love that there's a museum show
happening of her work in this it just
seems so
fitting excuse the punch
and yeah i don't know if you can tell us
but did you keep any of the costumes
because i would have
um i was very lucky actually so because
because we get to see beth grow up i was
afforded the wonderful
luxury and opportunity to really work
with gabrielle like we went in
deep together and i was like okay then
she sees this movie so i'm really
thinking this kind of outfit and she
would come out and be like but let's
make it green
i was like yes um so it was like it was
a wonderful collaborative experience
and at the end because they're all
thrift shop clothes she goes
you picked them like take them home but
now they're in a museum in brooklyn so
i'm going to have to wait
i think so i hope so um
they are so beautiful and it was so
helpful
as a way of charting where we were in
the story because there were some days
where
because of our locations we were
shooting
15 year old beth 19 year old beth 21
year old beth and it really does
when you i mean it sounds obvious but
changing the wig and then putting on the
different clothes it immediately set my
brain for
this is how you walk this is how you you
know intonate your speech this is what
you're in now
so i'm massively grateful for all of it
when jolene shows up you know in the
final episode like her
her outfit and her hair and everything
about her says so much about that
character
um moses it's actually funny that you
mentioned playing both young
and and older jolene i i didn't realize
at first it was the same actress
i've been getting so many dms of
different people
saying different things like i can't
find the younger actress
i'm like it's it's me it's awesome like
i'm that good
i'm both i'm both jolene's
that's amazing i actually want to talk
about that because
um the show was number one on netflix um
and people have responded to it it's so
strongly bill i know you were saying
before we started that that you've never
seen a response like this
why do you think people have responded
so strongly to this show and this
these characters
uh is that for me i it's
it's one of those things you know we
certainly knew we had made something of
quality
and you know we were blessed with these
incredible actors
um and uh you know we were supported by
the studio
and um you know it's a a lot of work to
hone it and and get it to all play and
get the visual effects working and all
of that
and so we were proud of it but uh you
know i think we're all
kind of pinch me i must be dreaming in
terms of just how
universally it's been
accepted you know it just came out last
friday
and it's been one of those kind of viral
feelings where just people discover it
and you know word of mouth
i mean you you can't beat word of mouth
it's
uh people telling other people like you
gotta
see this and uh it just seems like it
somehow came at the right time uh you
know it clearly struck a nerve for
people
uh you know this has been one of the
most
profoundly upside down years probably in
human history in some way and i think
you know to walk in beth harmon's shoes
and experience the journey that she
takes
uh and the span of years and the
people she meets and uh to see
you know her talent and to see her
kind of overcoming all the challenges
she has it just seems like it
was a story that people needed needed
right now
anyone else have any theories
yeah no go ahead anya no i literally
just said that nearly made me cry that
was that was my contribution
uh yeah i'm not sure what i can add to
that
but i think that there's a lot of things
like thinking that it's not just
a certain uh age group or
um you know a demographic that's
attracted to it because of whatever
reason
it seems to it seems to be like
covering uh the whole landscape
and i would imagine there's lots of
reasons one being the collective kind of
uh chaos of this last eight nine months
and the need for like you said bill the
timing is perfect
and and and it's such
a it's kind of it's interesting my son
is studying the
hero myth right now and i have to say
that there's there are these parallels
parallels
where beth is kind of a hero or is
absolutely a hero and in the way that he
uh she kind of takes on this
quest with this special gift
uh i also threw
and the fact that she actually uh you
know overcomes them
and which is which is human though
and it's uh it's really uh just the
uplifting nature of the
the kind of you know uh
you know that we that we get in touch
with
the the strong you know good parts of
our humanity
after you know suffering uh i think
that there's a lot of stuff that in this
as well as
just like bill you know you're saying
the production value is insane it's just
so incredible and i think it transports
people in a way as well and it gets an
older generation as well in touch with
the time that they
are looking back on and then there's the
curiosity of
you know for younger people in the and
the way that also the chess scenes
are shot i think are just the tension
and what anya's doing and every one of
her opponents and it's like
that's not that easy to do to just shoot
scenes chess scenes
where you have tension and you
have like i'm i was literally my wife
and i were literally
like leaning into the screen because it
was
it was like what's good you know it's
not that easy to achieve that
and it it's just brilliant you know
it's really and it's collective
i mean it's funny we were so terrified
about the chess caves you know i think
the terror is what
drove so so much uh work and attention
around them
that allowed it to work you know
bruce was there to oversee it as well
bruce pandelfini
and stephen meisner the the
cinematographer just
found ways to film the chess that were
so unique for each game they each have
their own
kind of vocabulary and way of filming
and that's
really hard to do i was scared for you
guys i was like how are they going to
make this interesting
and then and it blew my mind because
yeah even if you don't like chess you
can get so invested in the games um i'm
curious about uh the chess actually and
actually we have a question from david
polson
um wants to let anya know that uh he
worked in the production office of the
new mutants he's saying hi
um you're incredible in the show what
was the process for being
so convincing convincingly adept at
playing chess in the film
or are you in fact a grandmaster
no i wish i had to have a theoretical
understanding of chess because i could
in no good consciousness like just
rock up and pretend that i understood
what i was doing
because you know chess means a lot to
the people that care about it so i had
to understand
it but applying that theoretical
knowledge to
an eight-hour game is a very different
story so the way that we
ended up shooting it was i developed
with like my own way of moving the
pieces that to me said something about
who beth was
and then i would learn each game five
minutes before we did it
and that was the only way of like just
how many games did we have
like how many 203 like it was a lot so
the only way of doing it was just five
minutes before each game i had to learn
it and then
execute did you have any experience
either you or bill camp did you have any
experience with chess before this game
like even
a casual player
i've never played uh wow
i feel so lucky that our i mean at least
my introduction
came from people who were masters of the
game like my
appreciation and my respect and my love
for this game like i play now
um and that was that was created by the
people who
i met who loved it so much
bill you played before are you better
now or about the same
ah maybe a little better
i can open better i can open better now
but bruce taught me i had i had lessons
with bruce
uh he lives in new york as well and so i
was able to go
and sit with him and he would just we
would actually have just have
mostly conversations that were awesome
and he would
he would talk to me about the the
the nature of the game and the history
of the game
and and uh and i would just pepper him
with questions
but yeah it was the same deal we had to
learn the same
you know isla and i had to learn the
same you know the the moves and the game
the ultimate
you know outcome of the game and why we
were getting there and how we'd get
there when we were shooting
but yeah now i can be my
my son my 14 year old son so
um we have a question from blanca uh i
guess this is for anya
anya and uh marielle uh this show deals
with topics like mental illness and
addiction and it was treated with a very
beautiful sensitivity
how did you approach this in your acting
i think sure
i mean i think the thing about um being
inside a character
is that you can't judge them so if
they're
experiencing something oh sorry i have
another visitor joining me
[Laughter]
um in a little bit i'm almost done
it's just like uh but you kind of can't
address oh
[Music]
there's a naked child behind me i'll
just do this to cover him up
um right now i guess you just
i'm not going to answer right now i'll
let you go first
oh my gosh um yeah
um mari go ahead
okay no okay um
a conversation that scott and i had very
early on
um was about so there's a lot of chess
in this movie
or in this series sorry and there's a
lot of
substance abuse and seven hours of
one-night chess and seven hours of
one-night substance abuse is not going
to be interesting to watch it's also
massively inconsiderate to the people
who struggle with substance abuse
um and at least for
like the the solo substance abuse
scenes it was very important to us that
you understood the motivation for each
one
so if somebody's using they're using for
a reason
what is the reason that somebody is
using it or that beth is using in this
scene is she drinking
to escape is she taking the pills
because she doesn't think that she can
win without them
is she punishing herself is it a
celebration is she very lonely
and uh yeah it felt important to make
them
each different without being bombastic
because i think that there's a
kind of culture of making drug abuse and
alcohol abuse seem like very rock and
roll and massive and it's actually a lot
more heartbreaking
the reality which is just quieter i
think it's a quieter way of
hurting yourself i agree for me now that
i can slightly answer
it was much more about clicking into
alma's pain and what was
what was driving her pain and she was
a character who was so locked in a
loveless marriage and had never been
able to fulfill any of her
kind of bigger dreams for her life and
that was so heartbreaking
for me to see a character like that
who's sort of a victim of her
era and never really got to have the
life that she could have had as a
pianist or as a mother
um so rather than
kind of thinking about the effect which
is the abuse of
alcohol and drugs but it was much more
about thinking about what was the cause
what was the thing that was causing the
pain to begin with
and clicking into that
i just have to say too it's it's so
lovely to see alma wheatley
um getting to enjoy raising her kids
while this is going on i love the
juxtaposition um
pretty funny it's actually wonderful
those are really hard challenging scenes
and i'm curious as actors if
you know they ever affected you
personally do you sort of take your work
home with you at the end of the day can
it be hard
to be in that headspace
was it for you anya
yes and no it was um
i yeah i showed up to berlin
exhausted to canada sorry we had a week
in canada and i showed up completely
spent having just shot these two other
movies and
that just left me with zero energy to
create
a barrier and to have an understanding
of this is that person and this is you
um i'm not method but
it's it was difficult to step out of it
and returning to henry clay
when beth is like you know the makeup
and she's been binging for a couple of
days and
that was that was tough that it hurt
in a good way i'm so proud of the scene
um
because i i think or i can feel myself
plead a little bit in it and i'm like
okay
yeah that was the right way it was
supposed to be
for me um as you see i'm a mom and i
have a lot of distractions so
i can't take my work home with me i have
to let it go the moment i get home
there's just like no way
um anya and moses uh we have a question
this series is
set in the 60s and yet the journey of
your characters feels so
modern um was it challenging to make
these characters feel like modern women
even though the text and the setting
are decades old want to go moses
uh yeah i mean i think
i think for jolene unfortunately
the world is not very different than it
was then
you know so like trying to uh
figure out what your lane is i think is
very much
the uh you know the plight of the day
in a sense what about for you
i one of the things that i loved about
beth
was that she seemed just outside of
society enough to be genuinely baffled
when people brought up her gender
and genuinely baffled when you know it's
it's one of my favorite things about the
show like she sort of represents
an ideal that we're striving for where
she's a rare 50s 60s woman who was born
without the book of you're a girl
this is what you're allowed to want this
is what you're allowed to speak like
this is what you're allowed to
do with your life and she just
wasn't born with it and so she kind of
goes about her life
thinking i deserve anything that i work
for
and i thought that was really beautiful
um and yeah hopefully we're
working towards that
uh we have a question for bill camp
wants to know what it was like
playing such a reserved character
uh massively enjoyable
really uh really no because
uh it's like a gift to play somebody
for me at least uh that reserved
because then it requires me to think
uh as opposed to show
do you know that i'm not i don't feel
the burden to have to indicate
anything that's going on in terms of
what
i want the observer to see it's on me
to actually think that stuff and then
the great challenge is
you know can i communicate that and
transmit that
in some way so you know it was just a
it was just a uh it's
um yeah it's a it's a great opportunity
you know to have somebody like that
the reservation is
you know there are reasons why he is
reserved
but it also it makes me think you know
mari and any are talking about motives
and stuff and
so every action or move that he had you
know either on the table or getting up
and leaving or
the way he was looking at you know young
bath it was all
what are those motives you know wise
especially
when he's so close to the cuff
you know and so quiet in a way
um but it also
i don't know it was great it was really
fun it was really fun that's all i
couldn't see
it was really fun it's really fun
it's great well we have a question for
bill horberg
um from carlos wants to know what
guidance did you give the composer
carlos rivera
the score does a great job of building
the emotion and tension without
upstaging the fabulous acting
well scott had a great team you know you
mentioned stephen meisler
cinematographer uh we got to give props
to his editor michelle tesoro
who just did a brilliant job especially
putting those chest
games and sequences together and another
one of his
you know long time collaborators is
carlos raphael
rivera he did the music for godless
for the pilot shot scott shot hope um
and that was a lot of fun for me i'm a
music school dropout
uh you know first and foremost and um
i always love when a director and a
composer
have a a pre-existing relationship you
know i had that with
anthony miguel uh gabriella redd
a lot of the economic uh factors of
filmmaking often lead the music to come
on at the end like spray painted onto a
car coming off the assembly line uh but
when the composer's there
from the writing and the scripting and
sharing ideas
and you know sending in little sketches
and ditties and
carlos is one of those guys who can play
anything you know he's a multi-uh
instrumentalist and so early on they had
decided
you know the piano you know was going to
be the voice
instrument of the score and he was
sending sketches and then scott could
share some of those themes with the
actors so
it all uh is beautiful when the score
can organically
grow with the whole creative process of
telling the story and it's
it's just serving the story in a in a
deeper way um and you know
the response to the score has been uh
tremendous
you know um deservedly so
all the richness and the you know the
thinking of how
certain things get uh brought back in
terms of
you know it's played a certain way when
it's related to
an imaginary game on the ceiling and
then it returns
kind of in more of a real world
vernacular and it's got orchestral
strings and
uh it's all very mapped out and
intentional um it's such a great show
and i'm glad the weekend is here because
now we can all go watch it again
binge it this weekend um i want to thank
you all
for watching at home and thank the
panelists so much for joining us today
and again congratulations on a great
series